[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en las 24 este es
un magacín informativo 100% dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre de liliana
valencia y aquí damos una mirada en
profundidad los hechos de actualidad de
la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
como hace 3 millones de contagios
confirmados y más de 70 muertos los
gobiernos del continente africano
enfrentan grandes desafíos para acceder
a la vacuna contra el coronavirus de
almacenamiento a bajas temperaturas y
los altos precios son algunos de los
retos mientras que china aprovecha la
situación para acercarse al continente
tenga una crisis en el sector salud
causada por el coi 19 se suma la crisis
económica en el sector de los
hidrocarburos ciudades petroleras del
país centroafricano sufren las
consecuencias de la baja en el turismo
eligen 2021 en medio de la incertidumbre
y en nigeria se estrenó la primera
película animada hecha 100 en el país
actores de hollywood prestaron sus voces
a los personajes de este filme relata la
historia de una niña que viaja en el
tiempo
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días porque las
naciones de todo el mundo compiten por
obtener suficientes vacunas para sus
poblaciones incluso a áfrica en donde
los gobiernos tienen aún más desafíos
que en continentes como europa o américa
no hay suficientes vacunas para toda la
población y los países industrializados
han reservado grandes cantidades los
países africanos han estado negociando
para obtener la mayor cantidad de
vacunas posible pero los precios son
altos y algunas deben almacenarse a
temperaturas extremadamente bajas lo
cual plantea nuevos desafíos
fuera de áfrica decenas de países
compiten para comprar las vacunas de
facer y bayonne tec o de modernas pero
en gran parte del continente las
autoridades sanitarias intentan comprar
la vacuna de astrazéneca de fabricación
británica la de scinopharm hecha por
china o la spotlight 5 de fabricación
rusa esto debido a que no es necesario
mantenerlas a temperaturas
extremadamente frías lo que puede ser un
desafío en las zonas rurales del
continente además china que se ha vuelto
cada vez más influyente en áfrica ha
prometido entregar su vacuna a los
países más pobres el ministro de
relaciones exteriores realizó una gira
por áfrica que comenzó en nigeria
el programa kóvacs que compra y entrega
vacunas para el 20% de los países más
pobres del mundo también es una opción
para muchas naciones otros gobiernos
están negociando con los laboratorios
pero las vacunas sólo llegarán en unos
meses esto simplemente no es aceptable
si se considera el hecho de que la gente
está muriendo a un ritmo alarmante en
este país los críticos dicen que será
demasiado tiempo es probable que el
proceso en muchos países africanos
prolongue hasta dos o tres años el
objetivo es vacunar a más del 60% de la
población mientras tanto el número de
contagios sigue aumentando en sudáfrica
una nueva variante de la enfermedad que
es aún más contagiosa preocupa a las
autoridades y en zimbabwe han vuelto a
imponerse restricciones con la esperanza
de frenar la pandemia y hablando de ccoo
y 19 vamos ahora a gabón donde la crisis
económica en el sector de los
hidrocarburos ocasionados por el coi 19
afecta a miles de empresarios de
diversos sectores desde hoteleros hasta
quienes trabajan en el transporte
público han visto reducirse sus ingresos
de manera dramática durante el último
año
frente a la costa de port gentil esta
plataforma abandonada es símbolo de la
gloriosa era de la capital petrolera de
gabón una época que parece lejana para
mohamed diab y un taxista que viaja
varias veces al día por esta carretera
que hace unos meses era muy transitado
pero hoy en día y pocos clientes la
crisis económica causada por el hobby 19
ha afectado mucho a la ciudad de trole
hoy en día hay muchas personas que ya no
trabajan al principio hubo el boom del
petróleo el conductor de taxi incluso en
los malos días ganadas por lo menos 30
mil 20 mil francos cdf a los fines de
semana podría ganar hasta 50 mil francos
se desea incluso podrías negarte a hacer
carreras porque ya había ganado dinero
suficiente
el petróleo es la riqueza de esta
provincia que tiene los principales
yacimientos de gabón el país depende de
casi el 40 por ciento de sus ingresos
petroleros pero en la ciudad desde la
caída de los precios y el estado de
emergencia sanitaria vigente desde abril
la economía está paralizada los
restaurantes son muy poco frecuentados y
los hoteles están casi desiertos
como ven ya no hay mucha gente la vid
reabrió su hotel recientemente después
de cinco meses de cierre su clientela de
turistas y empleados del petróleo ha
desaparecido los ingresos han caído un
70 por ciento en seis meses
en estimaciones de pérdidas lo que es
seguro es que después de seis meses de
inactividad todos los gastos y los
salarios que hay que pagar estamos
hablando de millones
o sea para apoyar a sus empresas el
gobierno gabonés desbloqueo facilidades
bancarias por cerca de 350 millones de
euros esperando así amortiguar el
impacto de la crisis sanitaria y
petrolera en una economía aún poco
diversificada
vamos ahora aplica oriental porque los
campesinos en etiopía sufren tanto a
causa de las inundaciones como a causa
de la plaga de langostas ambos fenómenos
amenazan los cultivos del país y la
seguridad alimentaria de miles de
familias
ale mayo wood ads redescubre su aldea
vacía sumida en el silencio y con el
olor a ganado muerto en el aire su casa
se derrumbó parcialmente durante las
inundaciones que golpearon la región
perdió sus animales y todas sus
posesiones nunca habíamos visto que el
río aguas se desbordara así este año es
inusual nunca habíamos visto ríos así en
la región al hotel de chengguan en
avenida de teherán lago las fuertes
lluvias de verano causaron inundaciones
en la región de afar en el noreste de
etiopía que afectaron a unas 250.000
personas y desplazaron a más de 150.000
la ayuda humanitaria sigue siendo muy
limitada los residentes han montado
muchos campamentos alrededor de las
escuelas como aquí donde un equipo móvil
de salud atiende a mujeres y niños los
médicos denuncian las condiciones
insalubres mojadas le empezamos hay
escasez de agua así que beben agua
turbia y sucia lo que causa infecciones
de la piel también está el riesgo de
cólera tifus fiebre tifoidea y otras
enfermedades transmitidas por el agua
ahmed omar perdió 4 hectáreas de tierra
de cultivo el río se las llevó el resto
fueron devoradas en su mayor parte por
la invasión de langostas que ha azotado
el país durante varios meses
recientemente haro este campo para
plantar nuevas semillas 2 hectáreas
siguen intactas pero teme una nueva
invasión
intentaremos ahuyentar las como muy
disparos pero no estoy seguro de que
logremos superar la situación de nuevo
fuimos afectados por ambos problemas las
inundaciones se llevaron nuestras
tierras y las langostas se llevaron
nuestros productos en medio del período
de cosecha las langostas y el conflicto
en la región del tigre podrían empeorar
la ya grave situación humanitaria
vamos con información positiva porque se
lanzó recientemente la primera película
animada de nigeria dibujos diseño voces
todo se hizo de la a a la z en este país
en la historia de una niña que viaja por
el tiempo y vive los retos de cada una
de las de época de la historia a las que
visita
estos nigerianos vienen al cine para ver
el primer largometraje de animación en
la historia del país
[Música]
la protagonista es una joven que viaja
en el tiempo los productores de la
película tuvieron que superar muchos
obstáculos financieros al principio
pensaron que debían hacerlo en el
extranjero pero finalmente todo se hizo
en nigeria muchos de los que prestaron
sus voces son actores y actrices famosos
de hollywood la industria
cinematográfica más grande de nigeria y
del continente africano servirá para
mantener nuestra cultura y quiénes somos
como africanos la creación de esta obra
les dará a nuestros hijos la oportunidad
de escuchar nuestras historias y podrán
transmitirlas y preservar astérix
30 personas trabajaron en esta película
y su presupuesto superó el millón de
dólares sus productores ahora esperan
filmar una secuela en los próximos meses
noticias de lotes del continente una de
las principales preocupaciones para
áfrica 2021 es el flujo de migrantes la
preocupación por el alto número de
personas que expone su vida para llegar
a europa genera tensiones entre varios
países de ambos continentes uno de los
más afectados es marruecos desde donde
miles de personas intentan llegar a las
islas canarias desde allí nos informó
previamente
corresponsal sofía catalán la
militarización de las rutas del
mediterráneo ha llevado a muchas
personas migrantes a asumir rutas más
peligrosas como es el caso de las que
pasan por el océano atlántico en
dirección a las islas canarias estas
personas no tienen acceso a los visados
que exige la unión europea para
transitar de forma segura hacia su
territorio por lo que lo hacen en
embarcaciones no aptas para navegar que
salen en su mayoría de marruecos
mauritania y senegal en un año
centenares de mujeres hombres y niños
han muerto o desaparecido en el océano
atlántico aunque en realidad podrían ser
incluso muchas más porque la mayoría de
muertes simplemente no constan y el
flujo migratorio hacia las islas
españolas ha sido este año más de diez
veces mayor al año pasado como decimos
por el bloqueo del mediterráneo y la
estrategia del gobierno de españa' para
reducirlo pasa ahora por retener a los
inmigrantes que consiguen llegar a las
islas es decir las personas que son
rescatadas del océano atlántico son
automáticamente retenidas para ser en su
mayoría después ser deportadas y para
ello el gobierno español y también la
propia unión europea siguen reforzando
los dispositivos han de externalización
del control migratorio es decir el pagar
y ofrecer material de vigilancia a
países terceros para que persigan y
bloqueen las
de inmigrantes hacia la unión europea y
el país magrebí consciente de las
contrapartidas económicas y diplomáticas
que puede exigir a la unión europea se
muestra ahora reticente a ejercer de
gendarme de las fronteras europeas en
palabras del propio ministro de asuntos
exteriores naser amour y está lo que
muchos analistas consideran podría
servir para el reconocimiento de la
soberanía marroquí sobre el sáhara
occidental y en este contexto cabe tener
en cuenta que marruecos aparte de ser
país de emigrantes también lo es de
tránsito y acogida de inmigrantes y que
la ejecución de las políticas
migratorias europeas aquí impide al
estado garantizar los derechos más
básicos a estas comunidades y por otra
parte también tener en cuenta que españa
y la unión europea también siguen
reforzando los acuerdos con mauritania y
senegal para poder bloquear a los
migrantes y también deportarlos desde
canarias
y justamente finalizamos como sea que
nos llega desde marruecos donde nació el
artista il ya el estar radicado en eeuu
y allí grabó las imágenes de su nueva
canción titulada habib y con ella es
para resaltar las conexiones entre el
norte de áfrica y américa latina desde
boston hablamos con él
ahora para aquellos que no me conocen mi
nombre es filial y son artistas de los
eeuu de boston originario de marruecos y
quería compartir con ustedes mi proyecto
habibi que muestra muestra el norte de
áfrica en los eeuu y arroja una luz
sobre el otro lado de áfrica que mucha
gente no conoce como sabrás a américa
latina de marruecos comparten la misma
cultura en el sentido que de que ambos
fueron colonizados por los españoles lo
que dejó una fuerte influencia en
nuestra cultura es por eso que la parte
de la parte norte de marruecos habla
español como segundo idioma lo que me
trajo esta fascinación de comenzar a
aprender español e incorporar el sonido
latino a mi música realmente espero que
lo disfruten y aprender más sobre la
cultura norte la orden africana que
comparte la misma cultura de
latinoamericana porque todos somos
similares
seríamos diferentes gracias a france 24
y en mi gente de colombia con amor de
este boston pues justamente con música y
le finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días ustedes continúen con más
hembras 24 punto com
[Música]
[Aplausos]